le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
plus de 8000 tonnes c'est la quantité
annuelle habituelle de production de
letchis à la réunion cette année
seulement 1600 tonnes ont été cueillis
sur les 700 hectares de vergers une
situation tout à fait inédite qui a
obligé le département de la réunion à
réagir en décidant d'allouer une aide
exceptionnelle aux producteurs du petit
fruit rouge tant apprécié aussi bien à
la réunion de présentation
[Musique]
c'est avec beaucoup de tristesse que
raphaël avis regarde des photos de ses
pieds de letchis de l'année 2016 sur son
smartphone producteurs aux orangers à
sainte anne
il a connu la même baisse de production
que l'ensemble de ses collègues en 2017
la réunion a produit 80% de letchis en
moins par rapport à 2016
donc là vous avez des fruits sur les y'a
rien c'était comme ça les arbitres et
comme comme vous avez vu la stan et là
pas plus que ça donc
il y avait il une année normale sur à
peu près six hectares dont complot du
grosso modo entre 50 à 70 tonnes de
fruits ils malheureusement l'année
dernière ça va pas du tout été le cas
puisque on a on a une production quasi
nulle où on a récolté même pas une
centaine de kilos de fruits dès l'hiver
austral
les producteurs ont commencé à
s'inquiéter les fleurs sur les pieds se
faisait très rare et après la période de
floraison c'est à dire après jules hié
ou là on constate effectivement que sur
nos tables n'y a pas de ya pas de fleurs
alors commence à se poser des questions
et on se dit que je serais une année
perdue
malheureusement effectivement ben ça
s'est concrétisé on a eu une année et
qui a été à mon sens exceptionnel
puisque moi-même ça fait près de quinze
ans que je suis dans l'exploitation et
c'est la première année où je voyais mon
exploitation vide n'a eu quand même des
températures qui était au dessus des
normales saisonnières
et ça a un impact est justement ben
l'adduction floral savoir que les ti
pourquoi fleurir il faut qu'il soit prêt
c'est donc qu'ils soient issus bien un
stress hydrique soit un stress thermique
est là dans ce cas précis cela n'est
diagne est donc le stress thermique n'a
pas eu lieu puisque on a eu des
températures trop douces et à mon sens
cela explique un petit peu le fait que
blizzard ne soit pas pratiquement
production pendant la période de
novembre décembre
des arbres rouge est ce que vous voyez
qu'il ya aucun fruits sur les arbres on
se demande est-ce que
on a mal fait un travail quel problème
après ben c'est la nature on décide pas
forcément et là malheureusement c'est ce
qui s'est passé l'année dernière on n'a
pas eu de fouilles et s'est adressé en
même temps basse et c'est aussi grosses
pertes financières aussi pour la nature
n'a pas été conciliante en 2017 et à
provoquer des situations très
compliquées pour ces agriculteurs comme
raphaël avis en mono production le
manque à gagner colossal 90% de sa
production de letchis bio par
habituellement à l'export vers la
métropole et l'europe c'est une année
blanche fois loin là où on a perdu ben
la totalité de notre chiffre d'affaires
en sachant que ceux de nos exploitations
moi ici personnellement j'ai que du
letchi donc on trouve que sur cela pour
avoir effectivement une entrée d'argent
en fin d'année et malheureusement mais
cette année ça n'a pas été le cas et ça
entraîne des conséquences le compliqué
après connaît la baisse record de la
production de litchi a engendré des prix
particulièrement élevé à noël cette
hausse n'a pas comblé le manque à gagner
des producteurs généralement on
rencontre du du fruit à la réunion en
plein en pleine période 1 euro voire
parfois moins d'un euro
l'année dernière on a vu des prix à 8 9
10 12 15 euros c'est bien sûr le fait
avec un navet très très peu
morcheeba et fuir rapidement les
agriculteurs décident de s'unir face aux
caprices de la nature une situation
exceptionnelle qui peut obliger certains
à mettre la clé sous la porte
à la base on a eu quelques exploitants
qui sont regroupés en se disant bien
voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait et on sait
divers sollicitons un peu nos
institutions on leur explique pas un
petit peu le bel problème qui sait qu'on
avait rencontré cette année et à l'issue
de ce club avoir un petit peu mais
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous la portée
concrète pour pouvoir passer ce cap
puisque ben effectivement pas de
rentrées d'argent en fin d'année et nous
il faut qu'on continue à payer nos
employés et l'entretiennent au vih et
donc on a eu un une écoute et un retour
favorable de la part de nos institutions
qui nous ont alloué des aides justement
pour la l'entretien de nos vergers
espère avoir des fruits cette année
il faut savoir que nous avons été
sollicités par les agriculteurs et la
chambre d'agriculture au mois de
novembre dernier
très rapidement les élus du conseil
départemental ont décidé d'apporter un
soutien exceptionnel aux planteurs de
letchis puisque lors de la commission
permanente du 6 décembre dernier nous
avons pris la décision d'accorder une
aide à la préparation des vergers pour
cette année 2010 8 de l'ordre de 2000
euros ha d'autres conséquences de cette
année catastrophique pour le letchi
auquel on pense moins pas de fleurs de
letchis signifie aussi pas de miel
produit par les abeilles pollinisent ans
les arbres les miellés seront moins
importantes
n'en déplaise à certains un hiver
austral froid en 2018 devrait nous
assurer des letchis sur les étals de nos
marchés forains pour noël
[Musique]
suite à la baisse record de 80% de la
production de letchis à la réunion sur
les 700 hectares d'exploitations les 400
producteurs se sont mobilisés pour
alerter les différentes institutions le
conseil départemental a décidé de leur
allouer une aide exceptionnelle à la
préparation des vergers pour l'année
2018 de l'ordre de 2000 euros par
hectare les producteurs ont jusqu'au 30
juin 2018 pour déposer leur demande
l'aide pour plus d'information vous
pouvez composer le numéro vert 0 800 000
[Musique]